hello and welcome to this video playing
Zorro black here with the white pieces
so as always really black okay so we cut
them the elegance defense which is not
such a happy side for me I really don't
play you for often and rare openings
like the other kind system it's
difficult to face if you don't have that
steady experience with it but okay you
should be okay with normal developing
moves yeah this is some the modern
treatment of that opening they very
often take on e5 and then set up
something like c 6 g 6 i'm a position
that easily could have done come up from
from the from the scandinavian defense I
don't want to trade yeah as I've got
more space well may be here Shh I could
have considered that maybe
okay not sure about this but a 5-2 a for
looks yeah looked annoying to me so I'm
stopping it yeah I'm just going for
normal development Bishop g5 net bd2 may
be age six is an issue as Knight to f4
could happen not really i was in h6
bishop age four and then you might have
no def oh but II 7s hanging currently so
that's not going to be a problem in the
nearest future okay
I'm putting my dad wow wow isn't that
somewhat weakening okay so 93 well
taking is the easiest it's the easiest
moves i'm probably not bad 95 and then
Queen h5 maybe but I want to complete
development first so 95 might fc5
interesting but I need that I need to
activate him between age 5 and so almost
like that I have to have to go for
hmm wow isn't that annoying night c4
okay let's think about this for a moment
I can also take on f7 here not sure that
it leads to much so I'm going for this
one ok so how to do this now if I take
Knight b6 this route 28 it doesn't do
all that much maybe let's continue to
develop him
can take 27 again 95 ok but what now
after Bishop takes do have something
better 95 doesn't look bad but I still
don't see how i'm getting something
decisive going and it feels like I
should be able to do that somehow maybe
not like a win but something that gives
me an advantage I can go only for maybe
just attack that palm
so why can I not take the point is that
some b5 business I don't don't quite see
it so I'm taking root cake c6 also was a
move ya know I don't really love to
trade Queens here with this weekend King
position but what can you do let's to
play Bishop g5 I guess the other book
doesn't have that many squares
draw our third no but sorry not so easy
to get the rook into the play but
they're definitely not taking a draw
yeah okay three Bishop g5 again so i'm
going there at least a temple why not
this I don't don't quite understand i
think i'm sure i'm just taking taking
the pawns in
maybe I should have played 95 in this
position
yeah but it still should be really good
I'm 22 points up right there is no clear
compensation the pair of bishops but it
isn't isn't that fantastic here and then
I'm getting one of the bishops now black
resigns that's rather early i mean the
position is lost objectively but still
early resignation yeah I don't know this
looks like a normal position I guess
which got somewhere between the slight
edge and equal I think black is kind of
okay here with with this with a setup
but I don't really know if this is such
a great idea especially night to have
form after after the capture it feels
this feels wrong blacks young structure
is weakened and especially a form is an
issue yeah developing cannot be that bad
maybe not the most forceful move but i
feel that is looped kind of logical yeah
queen h5 is also a move that makes an
awful lot of sense but i couldn't really
figure out if there is something great
even if he goes here i 94 is a good move
I didn't see that one no and I'm winning
stuff but this isn't bad this isn't bad
either okay the engine wants to wants to
play this well I saw that but I couldn't
really i didn't see anything great after
work da the computer just wants to do
this then take on d7 and play looking
for yeah it's not bad but I don't think
that's my movies bury them no it'sit's
kind of
of comparable strength ya hear the
engine wants to watch the sacrificer
this is this is barely a sacrifice I
mean check yeah I'm actually wants
trapping trapping a rock right yeah I'm
trapping a look here even this is a move
it's funny a bit okay grabbing that porn
is it isn't a bad choice it just yeah
yeah I just had a foursome I think you
probably had to go kill yourself and
hang on hang on from this position I
mean here and i doubt that black has
full compensation for the porn but he
can definitely hang on here something
like this and go here and i have to move
the rook again and i probably would have
gone somewhere here and it's not easy
still to convert the whole convert the
whole thing now it's still still
reasonably tough tough to win here just
just another pawn a 95 or 93 also was
good but grabbing a second porn
certainly okay yeah yeah he resigned
twitter said I said somewhat early but
it's it is pretty bad the biggest issue
is that i just get to take this after
which he has no real hope for some
counter play it's two points and there
is no there is no weakness in whites
position that he can attack so it is
probably winning still with the time
situation everything I'm happy that he
resigned okay well thanks for watching